this is jocko podcast number 338 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
when i was teaching
close quarters combat
which is you know going into rooms going
into buildings and clearing rooms and
clearing buildings clearing hallways
clearing stairwells
there's all kinds of things
that a seal has to do correctly when
they do this and there are a lot of
rules
a lot of standard operating procedures
that you have to follow
how you enter the room
where your feet go where you aim your
weapon and where you don't aim your
weapon how far you stay off the wall
what you say
to your shooting buddy when you need to
move
what you how you respond to your
shooting buddy when he needs to move
there's a bunch of
[Music]
verbal and non-verbal signals that you
give
with your voice with your weapon with
your posture with your actions you got
to know how to give those signals you
got to know how to receive those signals
and then there's a bunch of calls that
you actually make
and again some of those calls you make
and you pass that word via verbal or
other types of visual signals
when to move where to move
what to address
in a in a particular room or in a
hallway or a building
because you got to prioritize and
execute when you go into a room there's
multiple things going on you got to
figure out which one's the most
important one you've got to support your
shooting buddy at all times that's cover
and move
you got to do all this with simple clear
concise communication you got to make
sure that while you're doing all these
things you're supporting the overall
intent of the mission which is
decentralized command
so there's a whole bunch of things going
on
when you're doing close quarters combat
and when i taught this
there was you know we as instructor
cadre
would get really critical about
the actions that the guys entering the
room made because we wanted them to stay
tight on the sops because
imagine you enter a room and you go
where you're not supposed to go you can
get shot by by your partner so so you
got to get guys to do the right thing
and then they've got to be able to make
decisions they've got to be able to make
decisions
quickly and so us as cadre
you know we would we would definitely
harp on these guys and
and
give them a firm critique when they
screwed something up hey you're too far
off the wall or you should address that
open door first or that you didn't clear
behind that couch over there so we're
getting on these guys
and there's a million points to critique
and criticize
and
we did that
we and again the reason we did that was
to make sure that they follow the sops
because when you get into a platoon or
you're in a platoon and you don't follow
the sops there's some sops if you don't
follow them in cqc
you can get yourself killed you can get
your buddy killed you can get the
everybody killed
so we're hyper critical now
as i watch that as you know as my cadre
as i watch my country you know i sort of
detached and would would let the cadre
sort of run the
those those finer points of the standard
operating procedures and i got to a
point where
you know i would talk to guys
[Music]
when they do something wrong
where i'd say hey you did what you did
let's figure out why
so so in other words oh echo went into
the room
and he addressed this door instead of
that couch first
you know and i could say hey that door
was open it's a bigger
i would say hey echo you you addressed
the the couch and you turned your back
on the door what were you thinking about
because i wanted to know why you did it
so that
i can learn more and it can allow me to
teach better right if i know why you did
something and you say well you know i
thought that the biggest threat was the
one that was closest to me well this one
might be further away but
if it's a bigger space to hide behind
whatever the case may be
so
as i learned why people made mistakes
that
helped me
be able to teach these things better
because then i could close some of those
loose ends as i'm teaching it
and i took this to other areas of
training as well especially with the
leaders right especially with the
leaders the young seal leaders trying to
understand not just what they did wrong
and point out to them what they did
wrong
but why they did it
so that i could adjust the training to
address the shortfall and i could
address and adjust my own
my own methodology of instruction to
make sure that i explained it in a way
that they understood why why we're doing
something a certain way
so i need to figure out i needed to
figure out
what they were thinking and why they
were thinking it and i learned a lot
from doing that
and of course we would do this type of
thing after missions as well you know
the the debrief
we get done with the mission we
immediately are going to go do a debrief
what happened
why it happened what we could do better
and of course
i if we had a uh someone on the team
that messed something up i would talk to
them about why they did it not just
ream them out because they screwed up
but hey what were you thinking when you
made that move what would you think why
did you move into that building what did
you think was going to happen
and and you know if you read extreme
ownership the first chapter after the
blue one blue
of course we obviously debriefed and we
created some new standard operating
procedures
to prevent
it from happening again or at least
mitigate the risk as much as we could
and if you read the rest of the book
there were even more situations that we
talked about in the book that were close
to being
catastrophic
fracture sides catastrophic blue on
blues
but we were able to
stop those from happening either from
our procedures that we had put into
place
or our better understanding of what
could unfold or our awareness of what
was happening
and when i got home from that deployment
i debriefed that operation that blue on
blue i debriefed it over and over again
to
the the seal teams
and the platoons that were going through
training and the troops that were going
through training to try and pass on the
lessons learned to everyone
and then we set up training
that we
we organized the training
so that
those lessons learned would get embedded
into these young seal leaders they would
understand how these things happen so
they could prevent them from happening
and i was told many times
over the years
that the training and awareness
that we gave people
prevented many friendly fire incidences
from happening and i mean case in point
jason gardner's got a few
in that he that happened to him on his
deployment to afghanistan where
he straight up said you know like if i
wouldn't have been aware if we wouldn't
wouldn't have had that blue on blue
training that this we probably would
have had a blue on blue for real
so i heard that many times
now
a lot of people have been asking me
about the horrific scenario that
unfolded
in
ivalde texas
uh psychotic
and sociopathic gunmen entered a school
and killed 19 innocent children and two
adults
and
i can't even fathom
the grief and the fam the the
just trauma for those families the
horror
the the hole in their lives that they
have now that can never be replaced
and the
potential
of life
that was
thrown away
before it even had a chance to grow and
it's just a completely
heartbreaking
situation
and
what has made the situation even harder
to process
was the
response from law enforcement on the
scene
and
of course we all like to think about and
talk about what i would have done
what i would have done if i were there
and and i get that everyone is horrified
by what took place
and we all like to think
that we would have been braver that we
would have been more decisive that we
would have had more situational
awareness that we would have handled the
scenario in a way that created a better
outcome
of
course we all like to
we would all give anything to be able to
create a better outcome in that
situation
and unfortunately
and the situation has already happened
the outcome is complete
and we can't change what happened
and what the response was any more than
i could change the decision a young seal
made when he walked into a room and
moved the wrong way
or addressed the wrong threat i i
couldn't
change what he had done
i i could tell him what he did wrong but
what i really needed to do as i said was
to understand why
why he made that decision
and learn from it
and then figure out how i could teach
other people to not make that mistake
and that
is unfortunately
the best i can offer in this situation
as well
now
there are
other things to talk about
with regards to contributing factors in
this situation
and
you've got mental health you got media
violence you got
dehumanization of people you got gun
laws and their enforcement or lack of
enforcement
and i talked about
some of those on the jocko unraveling
podcast with daryl cooper and all those
the thing is with all those those are
massive subjects
those are massive subjects all of them
that are being discussed at the national
level
and will take some unified efforts
to solve
they'll take some unified efforts and by
that i mean people actually working
together which we don't seem to have any
of
so as that conversation continues to
take place
i just want to
look at what happened tactically on the
ground and try and figure out why it
happened
and i'm going to use a timeline follow a
timeline from the texas tribune
it was last updated on
june 9th
and and just
just to note we're recording this today
on june 13th
2022
and it's just based on
simple open source reporting and i'm
sure that there will be more detailed
information available in the future and
and maybe at some point we'll go over it
with more detail but the thing is there
are lessons to be learned
even from what we know right now
that that i want to talk a little bit
about again from the tactical
perspective to try and figure out why
things happened like this
in this event
so
again from the texas tribune
this is may 24th 2022 around 11am the
shooter sends facebook messages the
shooter sends private facebook messages
to a girl in germany he met online and
tells her about his plans to shoot his
grandmother
the gunman shoots his grandmother
in the face and calls the police
the shooter steals his grandmother's
vehicle and drives from his home
to robb elementary school which is about
two mile two miles away
so
there you have a clear declaration that
something bad is going to happen made by
the individual himself
and i don't know if there's some kind of
a social media 9-1-1
call that you can make it seems like
it seems like there should be some kind
of a
social media 9-1-1
to call
where if someone is making threats of
violence via social media
that people that see these threats
can
have
someone to contact
where action can be taken
and i don't know if there is an ai
that can screen for things like this
my guess is yes
considering that
if i google search something
on my phone or on my laptop
the very next screen that i click i get
advertisements for whatever that thing
that i just searched is
so to so to think that we couldn't come
up with or that the tech companies
couldn't come up with something that was
combing through
messages combing through posts looking
for
threatening content
it seems like that would be a feasible
thing
and and at a minimum to have something
where
there's like a universal 9-1-1 call to
make if someone is posting threatening
things it seems like that would be a
move that would be able to help
these when these situations unfold
[Music]
moving to 11 28 am
the shooter arrives at the school
the shooter crashes the vehicle into a
ditch near the school he fires his gun
at two male witnesses who began
approaching the crash from a nearby
funeral home the witnesses flee and call
9-1-1
so so this this is at 11 28.
when you get a shooter that's
in the vicinity of a school there's got
to be a really good lockdown protocol
that happens
and this is something that when we talk
about lock down protocol
one thing that that
i think needs to be discussed
is if you have a shooter that's external
to the school lock the doors
but when you have a shooter that's in
the school
everyone should get the hell out of the
school you shouldn't keep people in the
school anymore
so
having a couple different
immediate action drills
when it comes to
when it when when a shooter
is either in a school we're going to get
out of school if he's outside the school
we're going to stay in the school we're
going to lock it down
those those require two different
reactions not one
because if there's a shooter in the
school you should get the hell out of
the school
11 30 a.m a teacher
calls 9-1-1
a teacher at the elementary school makes
a 9-1-1 call reporting the crash and
seeing the shooter noting he has a gun
the shooter walks toward the school
climbs the fence into the parking lot
and shoots at the school several times
again
if the shooter's outside the school we
should have an instant protocol to keep
him outside the school
11 31 am shooter walks to the school
parking lot the shooter reaches the last
row of vehicles in the school parking
lot firing his rifle throughout
police arrive at the funeral home so you
remember the the people that initially
reacted to the crash they ran back to a
funeral home called the police the
police now arrive at the funeral home a
school district police officer speeds in
the direction of a person they think is
the man with the gun reported by the
teacher but drives past the gunman and
head to the back of the school mistaking
a teacher for the shooter
so you have a problem of
positive identification now
where
you got teachers who are the only adults
in the schools
except for the shooter so how are you
going to tell them apart
this is where we look and say hey is
there an armband that we have is there
in an emergency everyone knows to put on
a certain
t-shirt or a certain vest and i know you
know you might be thinking oh that
sounds stupid if you've ever been into a
combat situation where there's multiple
people running around on the battlefield
positive identification is a real
problem
it is really hard to identify who's who
and you can make it a lot easier if you
throw if you give people some kind of a
uniform to put on where oh all the
teachers are wearing a vest that says
teacher on
an orange vest
[Applause]
11 33 am the shooter enters the school
shooter enters the school for the back
through the back door
he shoots at least 100 rounds inside
classes
classrooms 111 and 112 which are
connected
authorities originally said a teacher
left the door propped open
but later said a teacher closed the door
and the automatic lock failed
and there there's
she's
a quote here she she remembers pulling
the door closed while telling 9-1-1 that
he was shooting
she thought the door would lock because
the door is always supposed to lock
i've heard some people talk about
um
the horrible idea of or what seems like
a horrible idea of turning schools into
you know bunkers type thing oh you're
gonna have armed guards and every
and
look no one wants to bring their kids to
a school where the school feels like
it's a reverse prison right or some kind
of a prison environment where you've got
barbed wire you've got bars on the
window and all this kind of stuff
no one wants to bring their their kids
to school like that but there is a way
to properly secure schools
where it doesn't look
like some
prison camp
there's absolutely a way to make that
happen
and i think that just about any parent i
think actually any parent would be okay
with having some security in place
so that the school
is a a place where people can't get into
unless they're supposed to be there
so the back doors open look does this
mean i'm a little bit paranoid
mate yes
yeah a little bit paranoid
and i think a little bit of paranoia is
actually okay
a little bit of paranoia is actually
okay
so that was at 11 33
at 11 35
the the uvalde police enter the school
three police officers rushed to the same
door that the gunman used to enter which
was closed
they entered and receive grazing wounds
from the gunman they retreat
so response time has been
well 11 28 am the shooter arrives at the
school
31 he's walking through the parking lot
11 33 he enters the school the the
police arrived pretty quickly now if
there was some kind of security guard
there guess what response time is zero
minutes
and does this mean that your kid feels
like he's going to school in a in a
in a damn prison
because there's a
plane closed security guard there
i i'm okay with that
do i love it
no
i don't
but
this is not that big of a price to pay
to keep kids safe
there
the the idea that a guard or an armed
guard has to be some overt presence
that the kids have to walk by to get to
class oh there's you know mr fred with
the with the ar15 guarding us
i feel intimidated because i'm a little
kid i don't like i don't like it it
makes me feel uncomfortable
it doesn't have to be like no it doesn't
actually have to be that way at all
there can be a very low visibility
option for that
and it can be a low visibility option
that the children don't know much about
but the public does know about
and therefore it also you it also causes
deterrence
for a would-be school shooter
if the
would-be school shooter knows that there
are armed people in the school
they're probably going to figure out a
different target
so the police officers enter the school
they get shot at
receive grazing wounds they retreat
so
this is a tough one too with what i know
about you know the only words here they
retreat and that they that they received
fire
this could mean a bunch of different
things
this could mean
full automatic fire that is at the
shooting at the door that they're trying
to get through
and if that's the case and they proceed
in there they're just all gonna die
and now they can't help
or is it some rounds came
and
they immediately retreated i don't know
i don't know what happened there
i do know this
when you're getting shot at
you now have information
you have very pertinent information
you know the general location
if you're taking rounds you know where
they're you know at least a little bit
where they're coming from
so now we can start to formulate some
kind of a plan you also know that you've
got a high threat scenario and you've
got children in there
now you can't just put down cover fire
and shoot back at a person into school
because there's a bunch of kids and you
can get a friendly fire scenario
happening
so you can't just lay down cover fire
like you would over in a in a foreign
country in a war
but you know where the bad guy is
generally speaking
you know at least the door that you're
at he has covered which tells you what
there's other doors that he may not have
covered
meaning other doors where he may not be
able to engage
so we've tried one entry and we have now
information that we can't get in there
so now what are we gonna do find another
place to go
at this point going back to the timeline
here
pete arredondo the chief of the school
district's police department also
arrives at the scene around this time
he does not have his radios
eredondo wanted both hands on his gun if
he encountered the shooter and believed
the radios would have slowed him down
his attorney said
no
that's
this is not this is not
even a thing
there's not even a
this is not even a remotely
squared away concept in any way
what the radio going in
get go a the radio slowing you down
b
both hands on your gun i mean you don't
carry your radio in your hand
while you're shooting you have
you have your radio you have a
a mic to talk into if you need to
um
you
going into a situation like this
communication during an event like this
is beyond critical
it's beyond critical especially
if you're the chief
if you're overall in charge of what's
happening
you are the one person that absolutely
needs a radio and you know what so does
everybody else
now you don't always sometimes you don't
always have every single person with a
radio but if you're overall in charge
you're the one that's going to be
communicating receiving communications
giving directions
you're the one that's supposed to get an
overall concept of what's happening
now
this is an insane lack of judgment
and i would love to pull the threat on
this
and and figure out what actually
happened
my guess is
some
uh the chief didn't look in his car see
his radio and go you know what i'm gonna
leave my radio here
my guess is that's not what happened
that might be what the lawyer's saying
as a rationalization well
he thought he might need it uh he
thought it might slow him down
and thought that he want to have both
hands on his guns
on his gun that might be a a
post-operation rationalization
excuse
my guess is
that
in the in the panic of the situation
he didn't think about it and forgot it
and and by the way this points to a
an equally insane lack of training
because no one ever in any kind of
scenario ever where more than one person
is acting
in different parts of a team decides not
to bring a radio that's not a decision
that anyone is going to make
i would grab my radio before if i was in
charge i'd grab my radio before i grab
my weapon how you like that
so to be in charge
and to decide not to bring your radio is
complete and utter failure and you know
i've seen some things where they ran
some scenarios
like this
the training
if you train
one time doing this
and you're in charge you'll say damn i
better make sure i have good
communications with my team what if you
do this one time
if you approach a hostile target where
there's bad guys in there
one time no no hostages no children just
one bad guy you put him in a building
and you have you and one other person
you'll you'll make that radio
an absolute priority
one time now you take a situation where
you've got an active shooter and there's
a bunch of kids and you got uh different
units coming in from different places
you're gonna freaking need a radio and
you would know that if you had any
training whatsoever
here's the thing it takes practice and i
know this sounds crazy because
everyone's look everyone's an armchair
quarterback and everyone can sit there
and look of course i would have brought
my radio i'm telling you i'm telling you
this
it takes practice to know this
as obvious as it seems to everyone right
now
it takes practice you hear kids
screaming you hear gunshots going off
you're you're the person in charge you
you kind of panic and you go
you you haven't been trained to the
proper level and you go in there with a
route without a radio
so it's it's again reflects bad training
and at this point former officers
including a deputy
with the county sheriff's office also
enter the school at this time so now we
have seven police there against one and
again i'm gonna need to see the
breakdown detail of of the of the
building itself of where people entered
but you got more people in the school
now
and by the way by my numbers that's
seven police against one
shooter and i like those odds
seven against one i like
11 37
gunman fires 16 more rounds again
you have a
school with little kids in it and the
gunman is shooting
what that means is you go that's what
that means
let me rephrase that if you didn't
already get the signal that there's a
freaking gunman in a school
and you haven't done everything you can
to get in there and now that gunman is
shooting again that's
another
blaring signal to get your ass in there
and by the way these are not these are
lessons that have been learned
when you look what happened to columbine
they came up with these same kind of
conclusions
there was too much hesitation there's
too much waiting
when you hear this stuff happening
you have to take action
this is this is this is exactly the type
of scenario where when i start was
teaching the young seals i had to teach
them to be default aggressive
this is the exact kind of scenario the
problem's not going to solve itself you
have to go and solve it that's what you
have to do
and the reason that i had to teach them
to be aggressive and have that be their
default mode is because when things like
this happen people's natural mode isn't
to take action
for many people their natural mode is oh
i don't know what's happening i'm gonna
wait to try and figure out what's
happening that's what their instinct is
and we have to train that instinct out
of many people not all people
some people you actually have to train
in the other direction some people you
have to say hey hold on a second you
don't know you have no idea what's
happening don't go running in there
most people you have to train hey if
it's going on and you can't tell what's
happening you need to get aggressive and
figure out what's happening you need to
take action
and in a situation like this where now
you have a gunman in a school that's
still shooting it is time without
question to do whatever you need to do
to get in there
now at 1 43 am
rob elementary and uvalde police post on
facebook
they announce it that the school is
under lockdown status due to gunshots in
the area
by the way this is like 150 rounds have
been fired
the students and staff are safe in the
building the building is secure in a
lockdown status school officials say in
an announcement
so there's no emergency communication in
the building
is and what i mean by that there's no
there's no
pro word so in the military you have
something called a pro word
which is one word
that means something that means a whole
a whole scenario is taking place
so
if i'm out on an operation
and we start taking fire heavy fire from
the target building and we haven't
entered the target yet i have one word
that i can say and when i say that one
word everybody knows what to do
everyone knows that there's no
friendlies in the building that the
target building is shooting heavy fire
at us i can say one word and everybody
knows what to do
if we have people in the target building
we start taking fire i have one word i
can say and everybody knows what to do
so there's a breakdown of communication
here
because no one has put out hey there's a
freaking shooter in our school
that's gunning people down
no one no one knows this
so no one knows what's happening so as
you think through these scenarios you
need to come up with some pro words so
that everyone understands what's
happening
at the same time the valdez police
department posts on facebook large
police presence at rob elementary we
asked the public to avoid the area
so there's not communication between the
school and the police
do are there police radios in the school
that seems like a really obvious
question
but
does the
school
have the ability to communicate with the
police directly through radios
because this is not a very hard thing to
figure out
it's not a very costly thing to figure
out
11 44 am the police officers are are
inside
police with
with the city of uvalde are
and the school district are inside the
school this is 11 44. you've all the
police officers enter the building where
the shooter is from the north entrance
they hear gunfire
are shot at
move back and get cover
again
if you're getting shot at
you now have a general idea of where the
shooter is
and if you have a general idea with
where the shooter is then it's time to
maneuver it's time to flank
a a shooter can only cover so many
different directions at the same time
and how how do i know that
because i've been on both sides
of those scenarios
when you when you train properly you not
only act as the
good guys you spend time as a bad guy
so you start to realize what works and
what doesn't work
that's the benefit of training
back to the document around this time
aerodondo and another
uvalde police officer enter the building
through this south entrance
eredondo witnesses the gunfire he then
checks the door to the classroom that
the shooter is in finding it locked he
uses his cell phone to call for swat
teams snipers
extrication tools and keys to the
classrooms
this is at 11 44.
so all this has taken place
for
almost
over 20 minutes this has been going on
and only now we're getting a call for
swat team snipers breaching
[Music]
tools and it's on the cell phone
i mean how
why are we making calls on a cell phone
why is that happening
we have radios there's a reason you have
radios direct communication
instantaneous immediate direct
communication to a whole net of people
oh that's right well he doesn't have his
radio
so he's making cell phone calls
it says initial there's a quote in here
initial officers are there and receive
gunfire therefore do not make entry
officers call everyone in the area for
additional resources tactical teams
equipment specialty equipment body armor
precision rifleman and negotiators
they're evacuating students and teachers
during this time and this is from victor
escalante a dps official
during a press conference on may 26th
from the very beginning of this whole
thing you clearly have an active shooter
that needs to be hunted down and killed
that's completely evident from the first
moments
as soon as a car crashes and two guys go
to help and they and he gets shot at
or those two guys get shot at by someone
who then maneuvers towards a school this
is a active shooter situation and
someone needs to hunt this guy down and
kill him
and that's the mode that needs to be
gone into instantaneously
and
there's going to be risk
there's going to be risk when you're
going up against someone with a gun
there's a risk that you're going to die
and that's what
we in the military and law enforcement
sign up for
and we have to think through that
actually and you have to train for that
and the first time that you think about
getting shot and the probability that
you get shot
shouldn't be in an actual gunfight this
shouldn't be the first time this is
going through your head
you should do training
and you need to do training where you
understand what you're going to be put
up against
and you should understand what that
feels like and you should either get
over it and accept that as part of your
job or you should get a different job
11 48
there's an uh an officer's wife is shot
so you vow the
cisd police officer ruben
ruiz
can be heard telling other officers as
he arrives inside the school that his
wife
eva morales has been shot
so i you know you you look at this woman
the school teacher just seemed like an
amazing human
um
she's
got pictures there's pictures of her
she's you know outdoors she's enjoying
life she's out running she's hiking
she's doing spartan races
she's doing crossfit she's just
seems like an awesome woman
and and had a daughter with with reuben
ruiz
so he gets word that she that she's shot
11 51 am more police arrive
more law enforcement officials arrive at
the scene again so what are we doing at
this point
who is running things
at this point in time
now you got 15 20 law enforcement
officers
on scene
and he got one bad guy
that's a fight we can win all day long
all day long
we're gonna win and we might take some
casualties
but we can win that fight all day long
11 54 am there's uh an onlooker starts
filming
21 minutes after the shooter enters the
school
and onlooker streams a live video
showing parents begging police to enter
the school
now this is
very difficult to watch this is actually
sickening to watch
there are parents that are going crazy
with frustration they want to help their
kids
and in and in some of these videos you
can see that the parents are being held
back
by officers with long guns
with rifles with assault rifles
and and there what they're doing is
keeping the parents at bay
now here now here's what's difficult to
understand most likely i can just about
guarantee these officers that are doing
this have no idea what's going on
they have no idea what's happening
they probably think they're doing the
right thing which is hey there's an
active shooter in there my teammates are
in there killing this guy so i need to
make sure these civilians stay safe
that's what they're thinking
and why are they thinking that's because
no one in this this whole scenario is
detached and connecting the
pieces which is what needs to happen
when this kind of thing goes down
someone has got to take a step back and
piece together what's happening and put
together a plan
so these parents you watch these parents
they they actually are somewhat detached
the parents are kind of detached
because they can see that there's why is
this shooting continuing
why is this happening
1203
police continue to arrive and a student
calls 911 from inside a student calls
9-1-1 from room 112 for a minute and 23
seconds and identifies herself in a
whisper
meanwhile as many as 19 officers are
positioned in the school's hallway
19 officers
and now we know
that we got kids in there alive
and you have 19 officers
12 10 student calls back
student calls 9-1-1 again and says
multiple people are dead
so now you know for sure
the shooter is a psychopath that needs
to be stopped
that's what you know
12 13 p.m student calls 9-1-1 again
student calls a third time
authorities have not expanded on our
comments during this call 12 15 border
patrol tactical unit arrives
border patrol tactical unit members
carrying shields arrive
and
look ballistic shields are a great an
awesome tool to have
for sure
they're they're great
we're not waiting for this if there's
kids that are going to be killed we're
not waiting for shields to show up
12 16 pm student calls 9-1-1 once again
the student calls 9-1-1 again saying 8
or 9 students are alive so now we know
we got live kids in there
and we got
more than enough people to to to make
this happen
12 17 oddly enough the school announces
there's an active shooter on campus
i mean
what's happening
in our overall
from an overall leadership perspective
between the school and the police when
we have at 12 17
as there's dead children
dead teachers and now we're announcing
that we have an active shooter on campus
the onlookers the the parents are now
begging for action
here's a little pull out at some point
during the standoff onlookers beg police
to charge the school
according to the associated press
parents try to break windows and are not
allowed to immediately be reunited with
their children again there's video of
this it's it's sickening to watch
there's parents yelling out what are you
doing get inside the building go protect
the kids
and there's a one mom
one mom angeli rose gomez
she gets cuffed
she gets cuffed for quote intervening
with an active investigation
and
i can't even give this woman enough
props and praise
she she like
pretended to calm down
so that they would release her once they
released her she distanced herself from
the crowd got away from like all the
hype and all the mania and then she
jumped the fence went in and got her two
kids out
meanwhile
she said that other fathers got tackled
pepper sprayed and tased
again i i
somebody has to take a step back and get
control the situation and no one did
that here
and is there a chance that someone in
this group of people one of these police
officers happens to be a really good
leader and happens to understand what to
do in dynamic situations and happens to
have the authority and the leadership
skill to get control of the situation is
there a chance that someone might have
that there's a chance
there's also a chance that no one has
that and that's why you have to train
people so they can perform in these
situations and you have to and by the
way the training also is a screening to
see what kind of personality people have
and see what kind of shortfalls they
have as leaders and some people don't
have the cognitive capacity to make
these decisions and some people don't
have the the cognitive capacity to take
a step back
and some people don't have the
wherewithal to press through in tough
scenarios
and so as
as leaders we need to know who those
people are
this mom
miss gomez mrs gomez she is that type of
person
to take action to be default aggressive
get things solved she was detached
enough emotionally to realize she had to
get away from the mob get to a position
where she could maneuver in she was able
to do this
some people have that natural ability
some people don't and i'm going to get
to this in a little bit there's also
training that has to be overcome
sometimes people fall into training
habits that aren't good
so we have to train to the point that we
recognize when what we've been trained
to do isn't working
12 19 p.m
another student calls 9-1-1
from from room 111
hangs up when another student tells her
to 12 21 gunman fires again
authorities say he was believed to be at
the classroom's door
on a 9-1-1 call from a student three
gunshots can be heard
this is
over and over again
things that
would mean to me as a tactical leader we
go right now
this there's
time after time after time after time
there's
execute
criteria
a room full of kids there's a guy in
there he's shooting
you go
there's not a debate you go that's what
you do you go
you go through the windows you breach
the doors you do whatever you got to do
to get in there
that's what you do
12 36 student in room 111 calls back
again same student calls back for 21
seconds and is told to stay on the line
quietly
12 43 gunman shoots the door
the student tells 911 that the gunman
shot the
door okay
there's there's another execute criteria
and you do what you have to do to get in
there windows
you put ladders up to the windows you
crash you you crash through those
windows
you crash a vehicle into the windows
you shoot the door off the hinges
that's what you do
12 46
i can hear the police next door student
called 9-1-1
12 46 arredondo gives the approval to
enter
if y'all are ready to do it you do it he
says according to a transcript of
police body cam footage
12 46
12 46
over an hour
12 47
9-1-1 call from a student please send
police now
12 50
border patrol tactical unit officer
breaches the room and uses using a
janitor's keys and kills the gunman
and i i don't have i don't have any
details on
on how that actually happened yet
uh i've i know boar attack people which
is the border patrol tactical unit
bortak i know them i've actually worked
with them a little bit
i've got some reports that that they
disobeyed orders where people were
telling them not to enter and they did
it anyways good on them
but you know
what i've been saying this whole time go
in go in go in
and you think to yourself well if you go
in are you going to get shot if you go
and is this going to happen you don't
know
but look what happens when these guys
finally go in
they go in there and they kill the guy
that's what happens
you gotta go on offense
12 51
children are moved out of the room
so
12 51
106 police announced the shooter is in
custody
because the border patrol went in there
and killed him
and then you valdi
police
announce on facebook that the shooter is
in custody authorities recanted that
information later
[Applause]
so there you have it
um
what can we learn from this
and again
at this point in time i'm focused on
what can we learn from this tactical
situation that unfolded
what can we learn from it
i know there's a whole bunch of a whole
slew of other topics to talk about
and those are happening on a massive
level
and those will continue to happen
but as an area that i actually know a
decent amount about
is this
so that's what i'm talking about
and and first of all and i've been
saying this for years police need more
training
police 20
of
time
20 of working hours for police should be
spent training
that's what should happen that's what
needs to happen
and listen you think oh that that
there's now going to be less people out
on patrol less police out on patrol
their their effectiveness will more than
make up for the fact that there's less
police on patrol
who would you rather if you were in a
hostage situation with some crazy person
in your house who would you rather have
show up 10 untrained people or eight
highly trained people
if you're not sure about that let me
tell you because i guarantee you all day
long i'll take eight highly trained
people over 10 untrained people all day
all day
and i'll tell you
i am now i've started to talk to
some organizations
to see how
echelon from my company can help do this
on a national level
what should this training con consist of
what are we training policing
well combatives for one thing shooting
breaching
first aid trauma
de-escalation
and anybody that's listening that
doesn't know much about the police you
might think they do all this stuff all
the time they don't
they don't do this all the time they
barely get to shoot
i bet you 99 of police have very limited
training if any in breaching
in how to breach a door with a with a
shotgun
combatives barely any
barely any training
close quarters combat room clearing
urban combat clearance
how do you handle an active shooter how
do you handle a barricaded shooter
and then you've got to run scenarios
you got to put people into these
situations
you got to get
simunition or some kind of
round that can be fired at other people
during training you need assets you need
role players
so that people get used to it
and you will absolutely get better this
is exactly what i did
for a living
was train young seals so that they
understand what to do in these types of
situations and you can watch and see
them learn and get better
and over time they eventually get to a
point where they know exactly what to do
yeah they learn about the basic
fundamental principles cover and move
simple prioritize and execute
decentralized command they're gonna
learn about those things they're gonna
learn about decentralized command which
means when i show up and there's
something going on and i'm the junior
guy but i'm the first person there i can
make things happen i can make decisions
i know what the priorities are
that's what they learn
they learn how to detach you've heard me
say someone's got to take a step back
and figure out what's happening broadly
well that's what people learn when you
run them through the appropriate
training they learn how to communicate
they learn the importance of
communications they learn not to go into
dynamic scenarios without a radio so
they can communicate with the rest of
their troops
this
so much of this whole thing was people
not seeing the big picture no one
assembled
the entire scene to understand what was
happening
and therefore no one made the broad call
that needed to be made which is get in
there
get in there we're going
and this does take training
it does take training now it doesn't
take training if you're a parent and
your kid's in there that doesn't take
any training that's instinct
and i'll talk a little bit about that
but it takes training i had experienced
seals
i would have experienced seals that
would fail to take action when they
needed to and we'd have to have them do
that training again and maybe again and
maybe again until they realize that when
they don't take action everything's
gonna fall apart
so even seals would have a hard time in
some cases figuring these things out
now like i said the parents that were
there
they were
they were detached
and maybe not emotionally because
they're
they're
obviously horrified by what's going on
but some of the parents you can go watch
the videos they're making matter of fact
statements about what was going on
they're saying there's kids in there
there's shooting going on
now to this idea of instinct which i
mentioned instinct versus methodology
versus instinct
okay you have an instinct of what to do
and in some cases you need to get
trained against that instinct
it's just like in jiu-jitsu there's
certain things where your instinct is
wrong
and so it takes some training to teach
you to
overcome your instinct
to learn a methodology that's superior
to the instinct and there are times when
the methodology is wrong and the
instinct is correct
what do i mean by that i got a story
about jp danielle jp danelle
one of my guys
in my last deployment to iraq
and
outstanding guy
seal sniper point man outstanding guy
and when we first started working
together we were out in the desert
and we're doing a patrol out in the
desert
and the patrol stopped and i'm looking
at jp and jp standing out in the open
he's just standing out in the open
now we're out in the desert but it's not
a barren desert there's rocks and shrubs
and micro terrain features
and we stop our patrol and jp standing
out in the open
and i walk over to him
and i said hey jp if you were 10 years
old right now and we were playing war
where would you be standing
and he pointed over to a little bush
with some rocks around it with a little
terrain to hide behind and he said right
over there
and i said let your 10 10 year old
instinct
let it come to life
let it do its job that's where you
should be i know the standard operating
procedure is when the patrol stops you
set down in your position in your field
of fire you halt and you stay there
but if you can move
six yards and have good cover and
concealment that's what you should do
so sometimes people train to a point
like these police officers probably and
i've heard some some talk about this
hey it's a barricaded shooter which
means we
he's going to be staying there and we
should negotiate
so they got in this mode
of well barricaded shooter he's not he
we should just negotiate with him
the reality of the situation it wasn't
barricaded shooters he was moving around
he was still shooting the entire time
that's not a barricaded shooter that's
decided to hold up and negotiate for
some kind of ransom
not at all
they got stuck in that mode
what needed to happen was action
a methodical entry a perfect entry into
the building
if you were to plot out the perfect
close quarters combat
operation for this school and how many
people you would need and what
methodology you would move for the
building and what type of breaches you
would use on the doors and which would
be most efficient all that stuff goes
out the window when there's an active
shooter in a room with a bunch of kids
your instinct needs to be to get in
there
and some of those parents had that
instinct yelling get into the building
but the training methodology had boxed
these guys in mentally where they
thought oh well we don't have shields
and this is uh
i'm speculating at this point but oh if
we don't have ballistic shields we
shouldn't go in there
hey we were taught not to go into a
shooter situation an active shooter
situation without ballistic shields
we're waiting for the ballistic shields
no
that's the methodology been talked it's
not working right now
what about the windows
walking up to the windows smashing a
window
shooting through the window you can do
that
throwing crash grenades through the
windows
put 10 crash grenades through the
windows on this guy
there's a bunch of different things that
if
if you do what you would naturally do in
a situation you're probably right
so what you have to do is you you're
gonna have instinct you're gonna have a
natural instinct the instinct could be
wrong the instinct could be right
i mean here's an instinct somebody's
shooting at me i'm going to run away
i'm not going to go back so so police
officers have to overcome that instinct
to go and stay and maneuver towards fire
that's overcoming their natural instinct
but there's sometimes where the
methodology is wrong
and so you have to be good enough to
overcome your methodology and go with
your instincts sometimes
are you this is another thing i used to
say to these young seals
if you i'd say hey if you were going to
go in that room right now and i was in
there and you were 10 years old and i
was 10 years years old and i had a
squirt gun and you had a squirt gun and
you were going to enter this room how
would you do it
and they'd show me
and i'd say doesn't that make more sense
than what you just did and they'd say
yeah it does
but they would follow some standard
operating procedure that didn't make
sense in a particular room but they
would do what they were taught to do
even though it didn't make sense
and the ability to decide whether your
instinct is right or wrong
you get that ability by being able to
take a step back and assess and the way
you get that ability to take a step back
and assess is through training
and it takes time
and that's why i use that term that that
that id of 20 of time for police
officers should be spent training
and you're going to end up with
infinitely more qualified and prepared
police
there was a um
there was a fighting methodology a
combatives methodology a system
that was being used in the seal teams
and it was it was it was it was
ineffective it was an ineffective system
but one of the reasons that it was
argued
to be a good system
was because there was a one week course
of instruction of this fighting
methodology
that if you took this one week
course of instruction then you were
qualified
and allegedly prepared for combat well
you can't learn to fight one week
this is not gonna happen you can't learn
good combative skills in one week
and and so i was
bringing up to my chain of command hey
this combative system is ineffective
we should use
some kind of a more mixed martial arts
combination of jiu jitsu wrestling
boxing muay thai using our weapons in
those scenarios
and one of the arguments that i got
against that idea
was that all that stuff takes years to
learn
it takes it takes years to learn the
stuff this stuff we can teach people in
a week
well you know what i said to that i said
well we're in the damn teams for 20
years let people get good
you shouldn't tell someone that after a
week of training they're going to be
good to go they're not
training has to happen all the time
and by the way eventually we do have a
great
jiu jitsu wrestling boxing muay thai
based
combative system in the seal teams
which is you also utilize your weapons
you utilize your gear but it's based in
these things that work
and it takes time to get good at no one
says oh you've been through a one week
course you can handle yourself now
because we know that that's not true
so it comes down to training
and there's a look
are there a bunch of other factors a
bunch of other things that we can
address yes there absolutely are
there are a bunch of other things to
talk about
but like i said this is something that i
know and something that i understand
training people for stressful dynamic
dangerous situations and that's what we
need to do
with our law enforcement we need to
train them properly
because we owe it we owe it to them we
owe it to our police and law enforcement
to train them properly we owe it to the
law abiding citizens of this country
and of course
we owe it to the innocent children
that are just trying to get their
freaking education in school
[Applause]
so that's my initial take on this
scenario
again i i talked about some of the other
factors with daryl cooper
on our unraveling podcast
um
but i wanted to address this here
and try and get this word out
with that ecwid
charles
yes
you uh
you know like a lot of times where
sometimes when these things happen
you hear of like all these solutions
right whether it be on guards in schools
gun control laws like you know everyone
has their their take what do you think
are some of the solutions that
off the top of your head that are not
practical or doable or probably wouldn't
be effective
that you've heard
there's there's there's a whole slew
of things going on and there's many
facets that lead to this
situation
as far as i don't really think too much
about
hey what wouldn't work and one of the
reasons why i wanted to talk about this
is this is this is what i know will help
in a situation like this if you train
people properly they'll be able to
handle these situations
if you could snap your fingers and have
all the schools you know be totally safe
of course yeah
of course we'll take that all day long
we don't get to operate in fantasy world
there's crazy
mentally disturbed people out there
and if you haven't listened to that
podcast i did with daryl one of the most
shocking statistics that come out came
out
from it was
in 1955 there were 340
inpatient beds
for every hundred thousand people in
america
that needed mental health
help
340 beds forever every 100 000 citizens
those beds were dedicated for mental
health
wait they had that many available forum
just told not necessarily taken up just
available so
out of every hundred thousand people
there's 370 inpatient mental health
beds available in mental health
facilities right yeah
in
2007
there was 17.
yeah
17.
so that's a 95 reduction in the amount
of available mental health facilities
for people that need help
and by the way during this time we've
added all kinds of other crazy things
into the mix
with
drugs
legal drugs illegal drugs prescription
drugs
all kinds of media violence
whether it's social media whether it's
violent movies whether it's violent
video games all that's added into the
mix
the ssris
the the isolation of
[Music]
of being on social media in the first
place
the breakdown of the family structure
like all these things are happening you
throw those all those things into the
mix and then you have less
mental health
available
that's that's where you end up
it's one of the things that that you end
up so i don't know if that necessarily
answered your question about what would
not help
i try and look at what can we actually
do
immediately to try and start
getting people in a better situation
getting getting these things freaking
moving in the right direction yeah yeah
i was thinking um because i remember you
said something about uh like you're an
advocate of like having an armed guard
at the school right where they're
retired military or this was a while ago
um
and then i remember
hearing
the option of training teachers or
arming the teachers that's what it was
yeah do so
how do you feel about arming teachers
it's it's the same thing you need to
train the teachers yeah are you going to
train the teachers
because you've got to train the teachers
which can you train the teachers yes you
can you can train some of them some of
them that want to get trained
you know the armed guard thing my mom
was a school principal
and
and then she was a superintendent of
schools
and i remember when these school
shootings started happening i was
immediately like hey
you should put
there should be
two dudes sitting in a closet
you know with video cameras close
circuit television cameras they're
watching what's going on and if anything
ever happens they come out and kill bad
guys
i wish i would have been super vocal
about it
because some of these things would have
been
stopped a lot quicker
and then like i said
there's some people that say well you
know what kind of world are we living
into it when we need to let me rephrase
that because i'm i'm using a horrible
voice some people say hey what kind of
world are we living in where we have to
put armed guards in a school
i'll tell you the world that we created
the world that we created you need to
have armed guards in school because
we're we we've got
some serious issues
some serious cultural and societal
issues
that makes a an 18 year old kid want to
get a machine gun and go into a freaking
school
and start killing kids
that's what's that's why
so
if you say to me
what kind of a world are we living in
where we need to put armed guards in
schools i will say the united states of
america do i like it
do i like the fact that we have to do
that no
do i like the fact that i gotta
you know wear a seat belt when i drive a
car because i might crash i don't really
like it but i'm gonna do it
i remember i was in high school and
there was security there
they didn't have they weren't armed that
i knew of but i feel like granted this
is high school so elementary school is a
little bit different and
i'm thinking back if they were armed i
don't think that would have made that
much of a difference
if they were i mean if they were like
prison guards like you know ordering
actually these security guards are
pretty mean too to everybody and we're
like hosts you know i envision it where
they should be nice hot like almost like
nice teachers almost kind of a thing
like chaperones you know sometimes
teachers get like yard duty that's what
they call it in school where they go out
and
monitor they go folsom
no it was like well i'm tired okay so
elementary school teachers have yard
duty right certain ones and basically
they just go outside and recess and just
make sure no one acts up or whatever and
no one really really really really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really really really yeah yeah so
what you're talking about is people that
are people that are employed at the
school to keep the students in check yes
there's a difference between someone
that's at school to keep the students in
check and someone that's at school to
prevent someone from coming harming the
students yeah so those are two different
people you'd be looking for yes but in
in high school when i'm thinking about
the security that's what these and
actually there were ladies two of them
and they were there yes for to keep
people in check in all capacities but
what i'm saying is maybe one or two
levels
more advanced we'll say
is instead of two ladies with just
radios
they were
retired military or guys with yeah you
know with guns not necessarily over you
know with badges and you know but
their presence is kind of known or
whatever it's not intimidating it's more
of like a host kind of scenario
um you know like a like someone who's on
the kids side kind of a thing more so
than someone you know with their
eagle eyes open for any trouble you know
that kind of thing even though that is
what they're doing that's not their
presence that's not like but it's what
it feels like yeah you need to be
careful with that you if you're going to
have someone that's going to be doing
security they should be doing security
look can someone be dual rolled sure but
if you're going to put someone on
security like their purpose is security
you don't want them breaking up fights
over potato chips in the schoolyard you
know what i'm saying yeah you want them
to be focused on what they're supposed
to be focused on the is it smart to have
people that are dual trained sure but
someone has to be if you put someone on
security for the purpose of being on
security they should be on security
um now like you said and like i said
this doesn't mean they need to be
walking around with body armor visible
body armor and uh
and a weapon an assault rifle like
posted up they don't need to be like
that
but they
i mean they could literally be sitting
in a central location in a closet with
with closed circuit tvs
and when something like this happens
they know what to do
i remember the the arming the teachers
option and i remember uh kind of talking
to some of our friends that are actually
actual teachers and it kind of put
things into perspective because at first
i was like yeah that makes sense you
know it's not like you know give them
just a little bit of training whatever
but at least it's one more good guy on
the field you know with you know who's
armed and can protect but then
i thought about it after talking to some
of the teachers you think about it like
who wants to become a teacher
and then now becoming a teacher becomes
a whole different thing like right now
it's like i'm a teacher i want to teach
these young minds you know
to to get to the next level in life and
all this like basically all the the
things that people pursue being teachers
yeah over
um it shifts to something completely
different yeah that that being said i
bet if there was an option where if
you're a school teacher you can go to a
four-week summer course yeah on
you know active shooter response and
then inside of a school with
30 teachers there's three people that
have been to this course i i think we're
i think i'm feeling good about that yeah
yeah and they do a refresher course
every summer and you know what i'm
saying like you got you got to train
people
you have to train people properly yeah
but people are willing to train
because it's beneficial in a multitude
of different ways yeah that's
interesting i never thought about that
where it's like kind of the optional
training or whatever because i was just
thinking of it in terms of like hey
because this is how they
they'd say it i don't you know they
don't go into depth or nothing they're
just like yeah i'm the teachers yeah
like all the teachers they got done yeah
so so to your earlier question is like
what's a solution that won't work
the problem with that is
the the problem with that is the details
of any solution you take any one of
these solutions and there's certain
details that would make it better and
some details if you don't include them
are going to make it a disaster like you
just throw weapons into every classroom
with random people that haven't been
trained you you that's that's going to
be a problem yeah right because you've
got teachers that are that are that
might go crazy right there's all kinds
of things going on
so
you take any of these solutions
and you take it to a certain extent i
mean some of the
some of the ways of looking at things
can be so different depending on who you
are
that
like what's the term they use reasonable
gun control reasonable gun control means
completely different things to different
people depending on who you are and what
your background is so true and so to
just say hey we should have reasonable
gun control like i said that means
completely different things depending on
who you're talking to yeah so
that's why for this for this i just want
to talk about hey here's something i do
know about and here's a pragmatic
solution that will help
and it should be
it should it should be implemented
brad that's so true huh because
there are there's guys and this is going
to come as no surprise but when you put
it into perspective where there are
people who at six years old they got
their first gun six yeah yeah then
same country
same state a lot of time maybe even the
same neighborhood
there are people who've never shot a gun
ever in their life and they're like 60
years old yeah
so you figure someone who's never shot a
gun never handled the gun or whatever
the idea of a gun potentially can be
like that is just a death tool that is
just
a object of death so they just don't
know you know and then versus the guy
who got their gun at six and guns are
all around the house and cases and the
truck and you know all this stuff
where it's like no it's not a thing a
death is just a tool just like a saw or
a hammer or something like that where
you know how you know obviously people
say this all the time where it's like
hey you know if someone kills someone
with a hammer you don't outlaw hammers
it's like they literally feel guns are
the same exact in the same exact
category you see i'm saying but then the
guy the person who's never shot a gun
how he's gonna feel is like no a hammer
is to hit nails if someone gets all
crazy and starts hitting heads with it
that's different guns are made to shoot
people kind of a thing that's their
their attitude you know or their how
they feel about it so it's like yeah
then okay now okay now we need laws now
right for the guns but these laws apply
to everybody the six-year-old guy or the
got his gun at six
and also the guy who's never shot a gun
ever in his life these laws have to
apply to both people so it's hard to
land those laws you know effectively
where everyone's going to like them it's
very hard and
what makes it even harder is that the
two sides don't talk to each other
in a reasonable way
to try and figure out what would be a
reasonable solution
yeah man and so there i am using the
reasonable gun laws myself using that
ambiguous term yeah it's true well and
then yeah because you kind of
it makes sense on a certain level even
though it's still not effective right
where let's say i got a gun my first gun
at six you know 22
rifles freaking awesome
i grow up all kinds of guns right i have
all kinds of guns i've shot my kids
shoot guns all this stuff and then you
have someone a whole family of people
who live next door or whatever across
the street
and they've never shot a gun ever in
their life and they're scared of them so
now they're like hey you know they're
we'll just say highly intimidated or
something like that
so they come about and they're like oh
my gosh like a gun or whatever and then
the the person who's used to guns are
like how you're kind of being dumb
you're kind of being unreasonable right
now like this gun you have to pull the
trigger shoot you know point out
something pull the trigger for it to
shoot whatever it doesn't just
automatically kill people right
so you're dumb for being scared about
that kind of stuff
it's reasonable that that would that
feeling would would kind of take place
you see i'm saying and then you have the
opposite feeling where it's like oh you
guys are gun nuts like you have like you
have 50 guns 50.
i've never shot a gun in my life i'm
scared of guns and you have 50 of them
is it unreasonable for me to be
uncomfortable if i'm like that
seems pretty normal is what i'm saying
so i'm saying like that conflict makes
sense to me yeah there's just a total
disconnect yeah ineffective ineffective
for solving problems but it's you can
kind of see how you can you can see how
the disconnect occurs but it's a
disconnect and the problem with the
disconnect occurs when
you don't make any attempts to connect
yes sir and i just look at you and say
oh you are a gun nut and you're crazy
yeah
and
you know i
it just it just falls apart and you look
at me thinking oh you're a
person that wants to take all my guns
away yeah and so i'm just not talking to
you yes
some chicken some you know
incapable chicken trying to
uh take away all you know my guns
yeah
disconnect disconnect
uh with that
if you want to support this podcast
you can go to jockofield.com and get
yourself some
get yourself some stuff to make yourself
prepared from a physical sense yep
because we got to be prepared mentally
how do you do that you do that through
good training you got to be prepared
physically how do you do that do good
workouts train jiu jitsu
and eat some good food take some good
supplementation
yeah the the training thing the more you
think about it and this might be obvious
to you but the more you think about you
understand how deep training and how
valuable training in every single way
like you get someone untrained in a
situation it doesn't even matter the
situation i don't care if it's swimming
in the pool
okay so if someone jumps in the pool
falls in the pool they can't swim or
they can't swim very well at all
now they're
it's dangerous for them now you get a
normal person who just knows how to swim
try to go jump in there and save them
they could get drunk they could both die
now
now you get one one person trained
probably gonna save everybody yeah
exactly right
so man you can take the most arbitrary
thing seemingly and you train someone
you're better off yeah it's weird how
people um
like
the funny thing is start with leadership
because you know i teach leadership and
people think that they should already
know how to lead yeah and so then you
start breaking it down for me like oh
damn i don't know what i'm doing
fighting people think they just know how
to fight i'll punch him when i start
seeing red better look out no it's like
oh you roll with someone that's you know
a jiu jitsu player yeah or a real boxer
that you go square off with someone if
you've never boxed before you square off
with a boxer he's not panicking at all
you're done muay thai
you get one kick one kick if you don't
train muay thai you get kicked in the
leg one time yeah there's a decent
chance you're done fighting yes sir well
from a leg kick yes sir there's a decent
chance you call it right there you're
like all right this ain't happening yeah
so
anything that you do you if you want to
be good at something you know the the
the thing i always use is guitar
there's no more reason that you would be
able to fight or lead without training
than you would be able to play a guitar
without training
it doesn't you just can't you can't win
you know like
someone that played basketball will beat
someone that didn't play basketball 100
of the time yeah the basketball one i
think is really good because when you
see someone playing basketball you'd be
like yeah you just take that ball
you can't hold it you got to dribble it
or whatever bounce it and you put in
that hoop like i know what to do now
when you go try to do it you're like bro
you can't even do it yeah again like if
someone's trying to do it too with you
or against you or whatever right you
can't even do it yep
so so imagine getting a gun you don't
know what to do with it but you think
you know what to do with it you know you
think you're just going to shoot or you
think
that there's going to be a dynamic
situation and an active shooter and you
think you're going to know what to do or
you think that people are going to be
panicking and you think you're not going
to be panicking you have to train in
everything that you do
think about even you
who's kind of trained in a lot of things
think about how many things like the
normal person is trained in pretty much
nothing yeah
it's like if you have highly like if
you're highly trained in two things
you're like a jack of all trades almost
kind of a thing think about it
bro we're not trained in anything huh
well i am well you are
[Laughter]
sure you have to think about like of all
the things to be trained in and i'm not
saying expert i'm just saying trained
you have like good
usable training
what four things
five maybe yeah at the most even
out some good stuff to train in training
yep
um you can get yourself some juggle fuel
jackalfield.com
check it out we've got oh by the way new
flavors
yeah updated yeah this is on
me on me all right yes you know
i wrote a book called extreme ownership
yeah well guess what
the early flavors
my fault
well here this is what you did i
understand i thought about this this is
what you did this is all you did tastes
good so you know when you're
when you're young right yeah did you
ever have those uh you know like orange
juice or whatever the concentrate you
know the one where it's like oh it's
like a frozen like sleeve yeah exactly
right and you put it and you mix water
right so
if you look at the dirt okay so my my
mom guys would get that for us right
there orange juice comes out that's
right so it'll be like four to one or
something yes so that's what they did
they did four
they fill it up four times and put it in
the pitcher right the jug or whatever so
oh yeah cool sweet later on when i grow
up in high school i look at it i look at
the directions it's three to one
see insane yeah so it's like they were
giving us the more watered-down version
of it we liked it loved it because
that's what we're used to yeah i'm
saying but i tasted the three to one i
was like brother's a little bit too
concentrated a little bit too sweet for
me a little bit yeah that's what you did
yeah because you're all used to water
yeah it's your main drink of choice so
you're like oh you put some monk fruit
in this new
energy drink all this stuff and you
seems like you're super sweet to me you
got the four to one going yeah but the
three to one is more our speed i think a
lot of us zips and you know it's really
like a two-door it's almost like it's
almost i was like nine to one so anyways
we got all all new flavors all new
flavors they're hitting stores right now
yeah so
go check them out they all taste so
freaking good
we're gonna win on taste now
like we we were kind of crushing
everyone because we're making it healthy
it's pasteurized it's
you know sweetened with monk for like
that's how we're winning
which is still the case by the way still
the case we're still winning we just
made adjustments
and now we're gonna win on taste so now
now you have
now you have awesome
awesome upside
and awesome flavor and no downside
so there you go so check that out uh
also you can get them at the fight you
get the stuff at the vitamin shop you
get it you get the drinks at wawa you
get stuff at h-e-b
you see what's h-e-b down in texas it's
like the big grocery store and it's
iconic everyone loves it
it's like when you're in texas people
are kind of hyped on heb yeah yeah hell
yeah yeah i rolled into heb people were
hyped
yeah
so check out heb we got you covered
there too because people have been
screaming let's face it down in texas
people been people in the game in texas
and they were i was getting all the time
for years i've been getting hey heb heb
heb took us a while we're in heb
if you're in texas you know the deal go
get some
uh if you want to get some clothing
that's made in america go to
originusa.com we got awesome clothing we
got hunt mine coming we got jiu jitsu
geez we got jeans we got boots all
that's made in america
it's made in america right here
so go check out originusa.com
help america help your community help
the economy
help shut down
slave labor
just just get on board with the program
that's what we're doing at originusa.com
don't forget we have a store
echo made up the name what'd you call it
first off you made up the names called
actually i didn't know you didn't rank
up the name 100 all right it's called
jocko store
so if you want to represent trained or
untrained but we prefer trained but you
want to represent
on this path that's what you're getting
discipline equals freedom which is true
the more you think about it the more
true it becomes actually got your shirt
locker shirt on today yes sir
one of the favorites the fan favorites
what's the deal with the shirt locker
sherlocker every month you're going to
get a t-shirt yup
new creative
design some designs have controversy
behind them i'm just going to say yeah
as it turns out some there was a design
that a guy emailed in
seemingly nice guy
i don't know obviously but emailed in
said hey his wife was offended by the
shirt oh dang he needs to return it
which one is it everyone must get stoned
no which one was it the anarchy
rip
oh okay because she thought it was
anarchistic yeah she was like it looks
too much like the anarchy symbol and i
was like
thinking in my head uh good okay but i'm
just saying so you made one just so
everyone knows you made like an anarchy
sign but it was a d
for discipline kind of turned sideways
it was there was a resemblance yeah
so it was just kind of a merely a
resemblance it wasn't a straight up [ __ ]
i'm gonna be honest it was an homage to
the anarchy symbol there you go it was
straight up it it served its purpose i'm
just saying it was controversial
apparently yeah so there you go okay you
get those from time to time but anyway
they're creative you know good good
design a new one every month
subscription scenario on jacquard store
it's called the shirt locker right on
subscribe to this podcast subscribe to
jocko underground we're about to record
some of those jackal underground
answering a bunch of questions talking
about life talking about other aspects
of life go to jock underground.com if
you want to if you want to get into the
game on that it's also how we're going
to survive getting banned
[Music]
we don't own this platform that you're
listening to unless you're listening on
jocko underground.com we don't own the
platform so we can get banned we get
shut down people don't want to hear what
we have to say
so support us that way we appreciate it
youtube
you can check that out psychological
warfare dakota dakota meyer just got a
medal for life saving
and he also so he's out just saving
lives as a firefighter yeah so support
dakota you can support dakota by going
to flipsidecampus.com and buying
something cool to hang on your wall
check that out i've written a bunch of
books you know what the books are
you can check some of those out i also
have echelon front where we teach
leadership to solve all the problems
that you have which are leadership
problems echelonfront.com
also we have online training at the
extreme ownership academy extreme
ownership dot com
all the little lessons that will help
you in every aspect of your life this is
about leadership sure but it's about
life
go to extremeownership.com
and enroll and you'll see me on there
you want to ask me a question you'll see
me on a zoom call i'll be sitting right
here saying oh explain the details give
me some context
so come and check that out as well and
also if you want to help service members
active and retired their families the
gold star families
check out mark lee's mom's charity
organization it's called america's
mightywarriors.org
and also check out heroes and horses.org
those guys are on the field right now
micah and the crew
and you can find us on the social media
stuff don't get isolated on there don't
get it all freaking spun up about the
comments don't worry about some jackass
you know
seven two nine alpha three who insulted
you don't worry about that
but if you wanna say hi you wanna say
what's up
echo's echo charles i'm at jocko willing
watch out for the damn algorithm
and to the rest of our troops in uniform
out there right now standing watch 24 7
365
thank you for what you do and also
thanks for the service of our police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol
shout out
getting it done secret service all first
responders listen you have a complex
grinding job
that requires you to be a family
counselor one minute and a tactical
assaulter the next
and it's a hard job
and we thank you for what you do
and we want to get you the training
that you need to make it happen
and everyone else out there
there's evil in the world
evil that we cannot understand
evil that will attack a schoolhouse
filled with children
evil that will kill innocent children
and kill
school teachers
and we certainly need to mourn that loss
but we also need to remember
that evil is still out there
and we need to do what we can to be
prepared
for the next time it rears its ugly head
and until next time
this echo and jocko
out
you